what do you think of when you first hear
the word mutant do you immediately
imagine cool supernatural powers? Sure,
these powers might make people mutants in
comic books. But, did you know that in our world we are all mutants? So, what do we
mean when we say the word mutant? And
what is a mutation? To answer this
question, we need to go back to the
beginning of human life:
the union of egg and sperm cells. Since
both egg and sperm cells contain DNA
we inherit half of our own DNA from each
parent. All of the DNA in a single
person's body is called their genome, and
to find out how unique we really are, we
have to compare our genomes to our
parents' genome. DNA is basically a set
of instructions that our cells use to
build proteins, which act like the cogs
and wheels within cells.
Proteins influence the way our bodies
appear, function, and respond to our
environment. The DNA instructions for
building proteins are spelled out using
four molecules called nucleotides: A, C, T
and G for short. These nucleotides are the
key to mutations. To be exact,
a mutation is a change in nucleotides, and it automatically translates to a change
in the protein product. Think of it like
a blueprint: when you change the
instructions, the final design will
change accordingly.
most mutations occur during cell
division, when a mother cell fully
duplicates its DNA so that each of its daughter cells can receive a copy.
Occasionally, mistakes can occur and one
copy of DNA that gets passed down might
be slightly different from the others.
The DNA that contains the error is
called the mutated DNA.
DNA mutations can occur in two different
ways. Somatic mutations occur in a
person's cells during their lifetime and
do not get passed down to future
offspring. For example, smoking can cause somatic mutations which lead to cancer
and lung diseases. Hereditary mutations,
on the other hand, are locked into your
genes from the moment you're born. That's because they occur in a sperm or
egg cell of your parent before or
shortly after they fuse into an embryo,
the first cell that makes you. Hereditary
mutations are transmitted to you and
your children, because your embryo
becomes the template for all of your
cell development. When a hereditary
mutation happens for the first time in
your embryo it's called de novo, which
means "new" because it didn't exist in
your parents. A recent study estimates
that every one of us is born with about
60 do novo mutations. On the other hand,
you may inherit old hereditary mutations
from your ancestors. Both old and new
hereditary mutations will be passed down
to future generations,
each adding to the genetic variation
within a population. Genetic variation
consists of the unique family traits or
characteristics of a certain population
within a certain geographical region and
it's the reason we're not exactly the
same as our relatives. There is no one
else in this whole world who has the
exact same genome is yours. All thanks to mutations! Most hereditary mutations are
neutral--as far as we can tell, they have
no observable impact on health or outer
appearance.
Mutations are an inherent part of life. So, why do we need them? If mutations did
not occur, we wouldn't have any new
genetic variation. After a while, everyone
would be made up of a singular, dominant
genome. This would be fine as long as
our environment stays the same. But our
environment is fickle, and nature selects
which random mutations help us
survive as the world changes around us.
This is how evolution works, and it
depends on the genetic variation
provided by mutations. Without genetic
variation, we wouldn't be able to adapt
to environmental changes. So, our
mutations don't necessarily give us
cool superpowers, but now you know they
give us the power to survive!